hello everyone
um we're going to continue now our
discussion of supervised learning
linear regression is the topic uh and
actually as we'll see it's a very simple
method but uh that's not a bad thing
simple is actually good
uh it's as we'll see it's very useful
and also the concepts we learn in linear
regression are useful for the
a lot of the different topics in the
course so this is chapter three of our
book
let's look at the first slide
as we say
linear regression is a simple approach
to supervised learning that assumes the
dependence of the outcome y on the
predictors x1 through xb is linear
now let's let's look at that assumption
so in this little cartoon example the
true regression function is red
and it's not linear but it's pretty
close to linear and and the uh
approximation in blue there the blue
line is it looks like a pretty good
approximation especially if the noise
around the the true red curve as we'll
see is is substantial the the the
regression curve in blue can be quite a
good approximation
so
although this model is very simple
i think there's been sort of a
a tendency of people to think simple is
bad we want to use things that are
complicated and fancy and impressive
well actually i want to say the opposite
simple is actually very good
and this model being very simple it
actually works extremely well in a lot
of situations
and in addition the concepts we learn in
in regression
are important for a lot of the other
supervised
learning techniques in the course so
this is it's important to start slowly
to learn the concepts of this simple
method both for the method itself and
for the the future methods in the in the
course
so what is
the regression model
well before i define the model let's
actually look at the advertising data
which we
i've got on the next slide this data is
is
looks at sales as a function of three
kinds of advertising
tv radio and newspaper
and here i've got scatter plots of the
of the sales versus each of the three
predictors individually and you can see
the approximations
by the regression line are pretty good
looks like
for the most part the reason
approximations on the on the left side
may be on the for low tv advertising the
the uh
sales are actually lower than expected
which we can see here
right
but for the most part the linear
approximation is reasonable partly
because again the amount of noise around
the curve around the line is quite large
so even if the the the actual regression
function was non-linear we wouldn't be
able to see it from this data
so this example of how it's a
this crude approximation which is
potentially quite useful
so what are the questions we might ask
in this kind of data and what you might
ask the regression model to help us to
answer
well
one question is is is there a
relationship between between the the
budget of advertising and sales that's
sort of the overall global question is
do these predictors have anything to say
about the outcome
furthermore is how strong is that
relationship the relationship might be
there but it might be so weak as not to
be
useful now assuming there is a
relationship which media contribute to
the sales
is it tv
radio or newspaper or maybe all of them
if we want to use this model to predict
how how well can we predict future sales
is the relationship linear
and we just discussed that already
if it's not linear maybe if we use a
non-linear model we'll be able to make
better predictions is there synergy
among the advertising media in other
words
do the media work on their own in a
certain way or do they work in
combination and we'll talk about ways of
looking at synergy
later in the in this section
okay well what is linear regression well
let's start with the simplest case we
have a simple
model with just a single predictor
and this is the model here it says that
the outcome is just a linear function of
the single predictor x
with noise with errors that the epsilon
so this is just the equation of a line
where we've added some noise at the end
to allow the points to deviate from the
line
uh the parameters that the
the constants beta0 and beta1 are called
parameters or coefficients they're
unknown
and we're going to find the best values
to make the line fit as well as possible
so you see a lot of terminology the
those co those those parameters are
called the intercept and slope
respectively
because they're the intercept and slope
of the line
and again we're going to find the best
fitting values
to find the line that best fits the data
now and we'll talk about that on the
next actually the next slide but suppose
we have for the moment
some good values for the slope and
intercept
then we can predict the future values
simply by
plugging them into the equation right so
if we have a we have a value of x we
want for what you want to predict
the x might be for example the amount of
um the advertising budget for tv
and we have our
our coefficients that we've estimated we
simply plug them into the equation and
our prediction
for for future sales at that value of x
is given by this equation
and you'll see throughout the course as
in standard isn't statistics we put a
hat this little symbol over top of a
a parameter to indicate
the estimated value which we've
estimated from data okay so that's a
looks sort of funny but that's become a
standard
convention
so how do we find the best values of the
parameters
well let's suppose that we have our have
our
the prediction
for a given value of the parameters at
each
each value in the in the data set
then the residual what's called the
residual is the
discrepancy between the actual outcome
and the predicted outcome
so we define the
the residual sum of squares as the total
square discrepancy
between
the actual outcome and the fit
or equivalently if we write that out in
detail it looks like this right this is
the this is the error the residual for
the first observation square second etc
so it makes sense to say
well i want to choose the values of
these parameters the intercept and slope
to make that as small as possible that
was i want the line to fit the points as
closely as possible
let's see
this next slide i'll come back to the
equation in the previous slide but this
next slide shows it in pictures
so here are the points
each of these residuals is half is the
is the
the distance of each point from the line
and i square up these
distances i don't care if i'm below or
above i'm not going to give any
preference but i want the total
square distance of all points to the
line to be as small as possible
because i want the line to be as close
as possible to the points
this is called the least squares line
okay there's a unique line that fits the
best in this sense
and the equations
for the slope intercept are given here
here's the slope
and the intercept so just basically a
formula involving the observations
for the slope intercept
and these give we'll call the the least
squares estimates
okay these are the ones that minimize
the sum of squares
okay
so and of course a computer program like
r or pretty much any other statistical
program will compute that for you
you don't need to do it by hand
so okay so we have our data for single a
single predictor we've obtained the
least squares estimates well we want to
know one question we want to know is how
precise are those estimates
all right in particular we want to know
what we want to know for example is the
slope zero if the slope is zero that
means there's no relationship between y
and x
suppose we obtained a slope of 0.5 is
that
bigger than zero or not
well we need a measure of precision how
close is that actually to zero we're not
it's it's maybe maybe if we got a new
data set from the same population
we get a slope of minus 0.1 then the 0.5
is not as impressive as as it sounds
so we need what's called a standard
error for the slope
and intercept well here here the eq here
the formulas for the standard errors of
the slope and intercept here's the one
we really care about this is the square
standard error of the slope
it's sigma squared where sigma squared
is the noise the variance of the of the
of the um
the errors around the
the
the line
and
this
is interesting it says this is the
spread of the x's around their mean
this actually makes sense it says the
standard error of the slope is bigger if
my noise variance is bigger that makes
sense the more noise around the line the
less precise the slope
this says the more spread out the x's
the more precise the slope is
and that actually makes sense i go back
to this
slide right
the more spread out these points are the
more i have the slope pinned down right
imagine think of like a teeter-totter
right imagine i have a i had the points
they were all actually concentrated
around 150.
then this slope could vary a lot right
this i could move this thing up and down
this line up and down or sorry i could i
could turn it change the slope and still
fit the points about the same but the
more this the points are spread out in x
across the horizontal axis the better
pinned down i have the slope
the less um
slop it has to turn
so this also says if you have you have a
choice of which which observations to to
measure
and sort of in maybe an experiment where
you can design you should take you could
you should pick your predictor values
the x's as spread out as possible in
order to get the slopes
estimated as precisely as possible
okay so that's the formula for the
standard error of the
of the slope and for the intercept
okay and what do we do these well we've
one thing we can do is form what's
called confidence intervals
so
a confidence interval is defined as a as
a range
as a range so that
it has a property that with high
confidence
95 percent say which we the number that
we'll pick
um
that that range contains the true value
with prob with that confidence
in other words well
to me specific if you want a confidence
interval of 95 we take
the estimate of our slope plus or minus
twice the estimated standard error
and this
if errors are normally distributed which
we typically assume approximately this
will contain the true value the true
slope
with
probability of
0.95
okay okay so what we get from that is a
confidence interval which is a lower
point
and an upper point
which contains a true value with
probability 0.95 under repeated sampling
now what does that mean that's going to
be a little tricky to interpret that
let's see a little more detail what that
actually means
let's think of a true value of beta beta
one
which might be zero in particular which
means there's the slope is zero
and now let's draw a line at beta one
now imagine that we draw a data set like
the one we drew and we get a confidence
interval from this formula
and that confidence interval looks like
this
so i can this one contains a true value
because i've got the line that's in
between in the bracket
now i get a second data set in the same
population and i form its confidence
interval
from that data set
it looks a little different but it also
contains a true value
now i get a third data set
and i do the least squares computation
like form the confidence interval
uh unluckily it doesn't contain the true
value it's sitting over here it's
there's it's above beta one beta one's
below the whole interval
and i get another data set maybe i miss
on the other side this time
and then get another data set and i
contain the true value
so we can imagine doing this this
experiment many many times each time
getting a new data set from the
population doing the least squares
computation and forming the confidence
interval
and what the theory tells us is that
if i form say 100 confidence intervals
100 of these brackets
i will um
95 of the time they will contain the
true value
the other 5 of the time they'll not
contain the true value
so i can be i can be pretty sure that
the the the the interval contains the
true value
if i form the confidence interval in
this way i can be sure at probability
0.95
so for the advertising data the
confidence interval
uh for beta1
is
0.042.053
this is for i think it's for tv sales
so this tells me that
the true slope for for tv advertising
um
is
first of all it's it's greater than zero
in other words having tv advertising
does have a positive effect on
sales as one would expect
okay so that completes our discussion of
standard errors and confidence intervals
in the next segment we'll talk about
hypothesis testing which is a closely
related idea to confidence intervals